مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى تغطيتنا المستمره
على شاشه العربيه للاحداث المتفجره في
السودان حيث تدخل المواجهات اسبوعها
الثاني بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
هذه الاثناء تتواصل الجهود الدوليه لوقف
الحرب الدول الاعضاء الخمسه في مجلس الامن
تجري مناقشات بينها بشان احتمال عقد جلسه
مفتوحه لمجلس الامن الدولي عن السوداني
غدا الاحد او بعد غد الاثنين وقالت بعثه
السوداني في الامم المتحده للعربيه ان
الجلسه المقرره سيتم عقدها وابقى قواعد
الاجراءات الدوليه ولا يمكن منع عقد
الاجتماع طالما تم طلبه من بعض اعضاء
المجلس للخروج بنتائج مرضيه مراسل العربيه
افاد في هذا السياق بان بريطانيا تريد عقد
جلسه مفتوحه بمجلس الامن حول السودان خلال
يومين
[موسيقى]
اذا ورغم الهدنه المعلنه تتواصل
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وسط سماع دوي انفجارات
في مناطق مختلفه بالعاصمه الخرطوم خاصه في
محيط القصر الرئاسي والقياده العامه ومطار
الخرطوم المواجهات خلفت سقوط سته قتل اثر
سقوط قذيفه بمنطقه المنصوره في ام درمان
تقارير محليه سودانيه تحدثت عن اشتباكات
عنيفه شرق النيل وشارع الصحافه الجنوبي
الخرطوم فيما قالت نقابه اطباء السودان ان
الاشتباكات تتسع خارج الخرطوم وان 256
مدنيا سقطوا قتلى في المواجهات وجرح
1454 اخرون الانباء متضاربه ايضا حول
عمليات الطرفين العسكريه حيث شهد وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم محيط القاعده العامه
للقوات المسلحه اشتباكات عنيفه واعلن
الطرفان السيطره على وسط الخر طوم
والقياده العامه فمن جهتها قالت القوات
البريه للجيش السوداني انها تسيطر على
محيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
بالخرطوم اما قوات الدعم السريع فنشرت
صورا لما قالت انه انتشار لعناصرها في
شوارع وسط الخرطوم فيما نفى الجيش ذلك كما
نشرت الدعم السريع صورا للاستيلاء على
مدرعات عسكريه في شارع مدني بالخرطوم
الله اكبر
على مستوى الدوله السودانيه
للقتال والشراسه والبساله
وندافع عن
الشعب السعودي
[موسيقى]
وحمايه الديمقراطيه والحريه والسلام
والعداله في واحنا هدفنا كله المواطن
وفي مدينه مروي شمال السودان افاد مراسل
العربيه بان الجيش احكم سيطرته على مختلف
المؤسسات الحيويه في المدينه ولا وجود
لقوات الدعم السريع يذكروا ان مروي شهدت
مواجهه عنيفه في المطار الدولي والقاعده
الجويه
نبقى في مرو ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل
عربيه نزال بقداوي نزار مساء الخير مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه النزار كيف تبدو
الاوضاع الميدانيه من حولك في مروي حتى
هذه اللحظه هل من تطورات جديده حتى الساعه
بعد ان محكم الجيش السوداني سيطرته على كل
محاورها على المطار وعلى القاعده وعلى
المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه مروى
لا جديد غير هذه السيطره وهذا الاحكام على
مسار العمل العسكري الان الجيش يتحدث الا
وجود لقوات الدعم السريع داخل المحليه
والمدينه وحتى الولايه الشماليه اكد هذا
الحديث الجيش يوم الامس عندما خاطب الجنود
القاده العسكريون وعندما خاطب القاده
السياسيون هنا تحديدا والي الولايه
الشماليه
الضباط وضباط صف القوات المسلحه داخل
الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشاهدي مدينه مروي
الامور نحو مزيد من الهدوء والاستقرار بعد
ان عادت الحياه في مروي الى سابق عهدها
بوتيره متسارعه نحو الاستقرار
من المواطنين الذين كانوا خارج الملوي
خلال الايام الماضيه الان بداوا في العوده
الى مروي
يعيش السكان الان عطله عيد الفطر المبارك
شاهدنا تنقل المواطنين من مدينه الى مدينه
لتلقي تهان العيد او استقبال الزائرين
ايضا كنا حضور
لعدد من الاسر التي فقدت ابناءها
والعمليات العسكريه داخل مطار مروي
الابناء الذين ينتمون للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه يمكن ان نلخص ونقول بان مروي
الان بدات في استعاده النمط الحياه
تدريجيا والحياه الان تمضي نحو
عليه قبل عشره ايام فقط نشير الى هذا
العاجل اسفل الشاشه الخارجيه السعوديه
تعلن بدء ترتيب اجلاء المواطنين السعوديين
ورعايا ايضا كذلك من دول شقيقه من السودان
اذا الخارجيه السعوديه الان في هذا الخبر
العاجل اسفل الشاشه تقول بانها بدات ترتيب
اجلاء المواطنين السعوديين
ورعاية كذلك من دول شقيقه من السودان
السودان التي تدخل اسبوعها الثاني في هذه
الاشتباكات والمواجهات بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني ايضا من جهه اخرى
مروي طبعا كانت احدى ساحات هذه المواجهه
الصور التي نشاهدها الان على شاشه العربيه
هي صور من العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا من كبري
المسلميه الخرطوم صور لتمشيط افراد الجيش
السوداني لهذه المنطقه كما نشاهد الان
واياكم على شاشه العربيه ومحاوله احكام
السيطره
الميدانيه على هذه المنطقه تحديدا وكما
ذكرنا لا تزال المواجهات والاشتباكات
العنيفه بين الطرفين الصراع في الخرطوم
تتمحور حول مبنى القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه القصر الجمهوري ايضا كذلك الجيش
السوداني الان كما يظهر امامنا على الشاشه
في عمليات تمشيط واسعه في العاصمه الخرطوم
تحديدا من كبري
المسالميه في الخرطوم افراد الجيش
السوداني ينتشرون كما نشاهد امامنا في
الصوره على شاشه العربيه ونذكر مره اخرى
بالخبر العاجل بان الخارجيه السعودي اعلنت
ترتيب اجلاء المواطنين السعوديين
ورعايه من دول شقيقه ايضا كذلك من السودان
كما جاء في بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
بانه انفاذا لتوجيهات الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وصاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد السعودي ايضا بمتابعه
ورعايه مواطني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في جمهوريه السودان معها اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه عن بدء ترتيب اجلاء المواطنين
السعوديين وعدد ايضا من رعايه الدول
الشقيقه والصديقه من جمهوريه السودان الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا ما جاء في
بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
وكما ذكرنا بان هذه الصور المباشره التي
نشاهدها الانهيالي افراد وعناصر من قوات
الجيش السوداني وهي تمشط هذه المنطقه
منطقه كبرياء المسلميه العاصمه الخرطوم
اعود مره اخرى لنزار بقداوي مراسل العربيه
من مروي نزار يعني نحن نشاهد الان عمليات
تمشيط واسعه في العاصمه الخرطومه ليست فقط
في كبري المسالمه الاعمال التمشيه بدات
يعني منذ ايام لكنني اسال ايضا كذلك عن
مروي وهي التي تم استعاده الحياه فيها بعد
ان اعاد الجيش احكام السيطره على القاعده
على المطار على كامل المدينه سؤال ايضا عن
المؤسسات الحيويه ايضا في مدينه
مروي كيف تبدو الان
المؤسسات الحيويه سواء كانت
وزارات والمصارف او المحاله التجاريه هي
الان بمامن تماما
مدوي لم تكن كمدينه اتحدث وليس كقاعده او
مطار
مروي كمدينه لم تكن جزءا من الاشتباكات
التي حدثت خلال الايام الماضيه كانت بمنئا
عن كل هذه الاعمال العسكريه
المؤسسات التي تتضرر المواطنون في منازلهم
خاص المناطق التي توجد في وسط مدينه مروي
لم تتاثر
حجم الضرر والتاثر مباشره كان داخل محيط
القاعده وداخل محيط المطار
كلما رافق الحيويه والاستراتيجيه والخدميه
ومرافق المواطنين لم تتاثر على بعض البيوت
التي كانت بالقرب من القاعده تاثر
المواطنون نتيجه لسقوط الشظائر وتمت
معالجه
ومداواه المصابين لكن مروي باعتبارها
مدينه
لم تتاثر فيها المرافق لم تتفها منازل
المواطنين بشكل كلي خلافا لما حدث في
العاصمه الخرطوم وحجم الاشتباكات التي
خلفت ضررا وخلفت دمارا كثيفا وكبير في
البنيه التحتيه سواء كحل المستشفىات او
للمنازل او للمصارف او حتى للمرافق
الاستراتيجيه وسط العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم طيب ماذا ايضا عن اعداد المصابين
وان كان هناك من عداد قتلى بعد الاشتباكات
يعني التي جرت في مرو ان كان من تحديثات
معلومات ايضا وارقام
خرجت من هناك بعد احكام السيطره على مروي
نزار
نعم عدد المصابين كان خلال اليوم الاول
نحو خمسه مصابين اصابات طفيفه حدثت نتيجه
لسقوط شظايا التعرض للمواطنين الذين
يسكنون بالقرب من مطار مروي وقاعده مروي
باعتبار ايضا انها تطل مباشره على مدينه
مروي
تاثر المواطنين صفوف القوات المسلحه فنحو
ما بين اربعين الى خمسين اصابه الان
تجري المعالجات الطبيه والاسعافات لهم
داخل مستشفى مروي العسكري ومستشفى كريمه
ومستشفى هذه الوضعيه الراهنه لعدد
المصابين اما مراتوا ضحيه هذه الاشتباكات
فلم يصدر الجيش حتى الان بيانا تفصيليا
يوضح فصيله نهائيه لما دار في مروي وحتى
لما دار في العاصمه الخرطوم من واقع ان
هذه العمليه العسكريه والاحتباكات ما زالت
متواصله وقد دخلت اسبوعات ثاني يوم طيب
بالنسبه للقطاعات الصحيه اتيت على ذكر
المستشفيات ايضا في مروي كيف تبدو
القطاعات الصحيه جاهزيتها ايضا هناك
الكوادر الطبيه ايضا توفر الادويه
وما يعني يتعلق بها الحاله الصحيه بشكل
عام
الحاله الصحيه الان مستقره الضغط على
المستشفيات لم يكن كبيرا ولم يكن كفيفا
حجم المصابين لم يكن بالقدر الذي يدخل
القطاع الصحي في مروي في ضغط
للتعامل والتعاطي مع اعداد كبيره من
المصابين والجرحى الاعداد كان مقدور عليها
حسب الطاقم الطبي والصحي وحسب الجيش تم
التعامل فورا مع كل الاصابات التي وصلت
الى المستشفيات سواء كان من العسكريين او
من المدنيين هنالك اطقم للهلال الاحمر
السوداني ذكر لنا بانه ايضا مستعد لتقديم
العون حالمه وطالما تمت او تم دعوتهم
لتقديم العون والسند لهم هنالك ايضا
تكادف شعبي ومجتمعي يقدمون الوجبات
للمصابين والجرحى في المستشفيات في لمحه
تعكس تضامن المواطنين في هذه المنطقه مع
الجيش
لاحظنا ذلك اكثر من مره لكن الان الامور
هي مستقره بتمضي نحو مزيد من الاستقرار
ومزيد من
لهذه المنطقه ولهذه المحليه في هذا الجزء
الشمالي من السودان والتي وجدت نفسها في
اطار حرب وفي اطار الصراعات مسلحه لم
تعهنها هذه المنطقه
منذ حقه التاريخيه قديمه لم تكن جزءا من
اي صراع مسلح لكن يوم الخامس عشر من هذا
الشهر
اصبح هذا اليوم وهذا التاريخ هو بمثابه
دخول منطقه مروي وشمال السودان في اوتون
معركه عسكريه محتدمه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ما زالت مستمره حتى الان اشكرك
جزيل الشكر نزار بقداوي مراسل العربيه من
وراوي على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
التي وفيتنا بها من مروي اذا مشاهدينا
نذكر بمقتل سته اشخاص واصيب اخر من عائله
واحده في سقوط قريفه بحي المنصوره السكني
في ام درمان شمالي الخرطوم ورافقت كاميرا
العربيه تشيع جثمان القتلى وسط دعوات لوقف
الحرب
على المضروبين
طبعا احنا ما عارفين الحاصل شنو طبعا
ادانا طبعا التدوين من المدفعيه هنا ضربت
في
المغرب ضربت في الميدان ضربت حته ثانيه
ضربت
القانون
جنب البيوت قدام بيوت
وانا في الشارع
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه
دكتور امين مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
دكتور امين كيف تقيم المواجهات العسكريه
الميدانيه اليوم في العاصمه الخرطومه الى
اين تتجه برايك
صباح الخير مرحب بكم ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين اليوم بدا الاسبوع الثاني من
هذه الحرب
وبالتالي ما زالت العمليات المطارده
تمشيط في الشوارع والاسواق والشوارع
الطرفيه من العاصمه مستمره
الهدنه لم تصمت كثيرا
قوات الدعم السريعه توزعت كمجموعات ليس
بينها رابط ولا رياض مسيطره
وبالتالي بدات تدخل في الاحياء
وتطارد من قبل القوات المسلحه
ايضا خدمات الاساسيه ما زالت متوقفه
وعمليات المطارده تدخل من شارع الى شارع
فبالتالي تؤثر على الجميع اليست هنالك
مواقع محدده بالنسبه لتوفر المركبات
القتاليه
تستطيع ان تتحرك
كمعرك موبايل متحركه من مكان الى مكان
لذلك تزداد المعاناه مثل ما حدث لهذه
الاسره تترحم على الذين توفوا
ونتمنى الشفاء للجرحى
ما زالت معركه شوارع
ما زالت هنالك عمليات اضرار بالمواطنين
بالممتلكات العامه والخاصه
وما زالت المطارده مستمره من الجو ومن
البر لاجلاء هذه القوات من العاصمه وحسمها
مثل ما حدث في منطقه وسط الخرطوم التي
تعتبر اليوم هادئه
وكما حدث مروي ومنطقه الرئاسي
وبالتالي هي معركه كفوفر حتى الان
المواجهات تدخل الاسبوع الثاني دكتور امين
هل كان من المتوقع ان تاخذ كل هذه يعني
الساعات والايام ايضا دون ان يتم حسمها
بشكل كامل من قبل اي طرف او ربما الطرف
الاقوى الجيش
تحدثنا في اليوم الاول عبر قناه العربيه
تحديدا ان حرب المدن لديها قياسات ولديها
تكتيكات اهمها ان القوات المسلحه تستخدم
اغله هو ممكنه وتعمل بتركيز شديد جدا حتى
لا يصاب المواطنون
والمناطق السكنيه باضرار لكن قواعد
الاشتباك اللي استخدمتها القوات المسلحه
لم تستخدم من الطرف الاخر
وواضح انه هي اللي ادت الى بطء حسم
المعركه وقلنا نتحدث عن ايام اليوم دخلنا
في الاسبوع الثاني
والقوات المسلحه ما زالت تسيطر ولكن بحذر
شديد لذلك
برتقالات جنيه وكل القواعد الدوليه الخاصه
بالاشتباك في حرب المدن تحذر من استخدام
القوى المفرطه من اجل حمايه المدنيين ورغم
ذلك الان اصابات وسط المدنيين
يعني
كله هو ملتحبه تعمل على الاضرار في
الاسواق وهذا هو السبب يمكن الذي ادى الى
دخول اسبوع كامل دون الحكم النهائي ودون
نجاح اي هدنه وبالتالي ندخل اليوم في
الاسبوع الثاني ونامل انه النداءات
الدوليه والاقليميه ان تجد حزنا صاغيه حتى
يتم اجلاء المواطنين
والجرحى ولمسي من الاسر
دكتور من المستفيد من عدم الالتزام بتطبيق
هذه
الهدنه بين الطرفين برايك
من الواضح انه تعمل سريعه تريد ان تؤكد
انها موجوده تريد ان تعود الى مواقعها
تريد ان تحدد نصر حتى وان كانت هنالك هدنه
او تفاوض يكون لها مركز متقدم الان هي ليس
لديها اي مركز في وسط العاصمه
ومجموعات
لذلك هي تريد كل اي هدنه عشان تستفيدنا
تسترجع مواقع او تقويم من موقفها التفاوض
او حتى تنتظر دعم في علم الغيب فيصل ولا
ما يوصل وبالتالي وتدعم السريع هي التي
يعني احدث القروات ورغم النداءات ورغم
الاتصالات التي تجريها المؤسسات الدوليه
والاقليميه مع قائد الدعم السريع
لكن نجد ان حتى الفيديوهات التي تصور تصور
من الايام الاولى في محاوله لحرب نفسيه
لحرب اعلاميه لتقويه
معنوياتهم
انت تقصد يا دكتور ان بعض الفيديوهات التي
ينشرها الدعم السريع خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه بعد مضي اكثر من اسبوع على هذه
على هذا الاحتراب داخل السودان بان هذه
فيديوهات سجلت في الايام الاولى من هذا
النزاع والان يتم نشرها
طبعا ربما الضغط على الجيش او يعني محاوله
لعب لعبه نفسيه هنا
نعم يا حربي نفسيها وربع للمعنويات وراينا
انه اغلبها في اماكن هادئه يعني هذه الصور
بمناطق هادئه لا تعكس الصراع الموجود
حاليا هذا يعني انها صورت في الايام اليوم
الاول او باكرا او حتى هنالك تعديل في هذه
الفيديوهات من اجل
[موسيقى]
التصوير انه عندهم هم نوع من السابقه او
نوع من هنالك يعني ملاحظه حدثت في هذه
الفيديوهات ان هنالك شباب صغيرين السن
يعني نتحدث عن 11 سنه الى 15 سنه
ظهرت في هذه الفيديوهات وده طبعا مؤشر
خطير جدا لاستخدامه الاطفال في التجنيد
وزيهم في هكذا معركه ضد الجيش
مؤسسه طيب واضح الان فقط نذكر يعني بهذا
الخبر العاجل اسفل الشاشه بين الجيش
السوداني اعلن اجلال رعايه امريكا
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين بطائرات
عسكريه خلال ساعات اذا الجيش السوداني
اجلاء رعايه امريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والصين بطائرات
عسكريه خلال ساعات الجيش السوداني قال بان
البرهان تلقى اتصالات من رؤساء دول لضمان
اجلال عليهم رعاياهم من السود قبل هذه
الاخبار تابعنا الخارجيه السعوديه التي
اعلنت بانها بدات ترتيب اجلاء المواطنين
السعوديين ورعايا ايضا كذلك من دول شقيقه
من السودان بالاضافه الى المواطنين
السعوديين في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ابقى معي دكتور سعود اليك المشاهدين
اقبل ثاني ايام عيد الفطر والحرب مستمره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لا يزال
السودانيون يتعثرون بين مخلفات الدمار
الذي طال بيوتهم نتيجه القصف المتبادل بين
الجانبين
لا اعجلا عند الوداع قست الجدران على
صاحبها في قلبها سواد دمار لا غير يتعرف
هذا الرجل على منزل تغيرت ملامحه انقلب
راسا على عقب
والارض لا تسعه وان مدت له يد العون
حديث الرصاص في صباحات العيد احتفظ المكان
بالادله قذيفه ورصاصات طائشه يخمن محمود
الطيب تفاصيل ما حل بمنزله وصل العديد في
العاصمه الخرطوم
الحديد اللي فوق القزاز القزاز هنا بتاع
العربيه وهنا في غطاء كده من الحديد ضربت
هنا وقعت زي المسافه دي قدام رجله النزح
اهل الدار تركوا وراءهم حادثه بيت مدمر
نجحوا الى ولايات سودانيه مجاوره بعيدا عن
ساحه الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
مئات السودانيين نزحوا الى ولايات مجاوره
للخرطوم شمالا وجنوبا مناطق وان كانت
بعيده نسبيا عن الاشتباكات الا ان خارطه
المعارك تنذر بامتداد الصراع محتدم الى
اطراف الخرطوم وابعد غيداء السالم العربيه
تتعالى الصيحات الدوليه لوقف الحرب
الدائره في السودان بهذا السياق حضرت
مجموعه الازمات الدوليه من حرب اهليه
مدمره اذا استمرت الاشتباكات بين طرفي
الحرب المنظمه الدوليه نصحت الجهات
السودانيه الفاعله والجهات الخارجيه من من
تربطها علاقات مع عبد الفتاح البرهان
ومحمد حمدان دقلو ان تطالبهما بوقف القتال
فورا واضافت ان القتال خلف مئات القتلى
وحاصر الالاف متوقعه ان يكون عدد الوفيات
اكبر بكثير كما رجحت ان ينتصر الجيش على
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم وقالت في حال
استطاع الجيش من العاصمه وانسحب حميد الى
دارفور فمن الممكن ان تتبعها حرب اهليه
وتوقعت مجموعه الازمات الدوليه انما يحدث
ستكون له تبعات اخرى بتاثيره على
الاستقرار في الدول المجاوره مثل تشاد
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وليبيا وجنوب
السودان ونصحت المجموعه الاحزاب السياسيه
وزعماء القبائل بالاستمرار في رفض
الانحياز لاي طرف ومنع الشعب من الانخراط
في القتال وحتى اللاعبين الاقليميين
لاسيما مصر وتشاد واثيوبيا وجنوب السودان
واريتريا على تجنب دعم اي من الطرفين
هذا وفي نفس السياقه من الرئيس الكوري
الجنوبي بارسال وحده بحريه الى شواطئ
السودان لحمايه المواطنين الكوريين
الجنوبيين وقال المتحدث الرئاسي ان الرئيس
امر بنشر وحده جونغهاي لمكافحه القرصنه
بشكل فوري عند شواطئ السودان لحمايه
المواطنين الكوريين الجنوبيين وارسال
طائره عسكريه الى القاعده الامريكيه في
جيبوتي تحضيرا لاجلاء رعاياها من السودان
بسبب الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني
اذا ومع دخول الاشتباكات في السودان
اسبوعها الثاني اجر رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الامريكيه مارك ميلي اتصالا
هاتفيا مع رئيس القوات المسلحه السودانيه
عبد الفتاح البرهان اوضح المتحدث باسم
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه جوزيف هوستد ان
الطرفين ناقش سلامه المواطنين الامريكيين
والتطورات الاوضاع وما يحدث في السودان
هذا ورحب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن باعلان الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع التزامهم بوقف اطلاق النار لمده
ثلاثه ايام خلال عيد الفطر وقال بلينكن في
بيان نشرته الخارجيه الامريكيه انه تحدث
مع رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد القوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وحتى هما
على الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار خلال هذه
الفتره
نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اوضح بدوره انه يجب الا يتوقع
المواطنون الامريكيون في السودان اجلاء
تنسقه الحكومه الامريكيه وقال خلال افاده
اعلاميه انه بالنظر الى اغلاق مطار
الخرطوم والوضع الامني غير المستقر في
البلاد يتعين على المواطنين هناك اتخاذ
الترتيبات الخاصه بهم للبقاء في امان
نظرا للوضع الامني غير المستقر في الخرطوم
وقرار اغلاق المطار انه غير امن حاليا
اجراء اخلاء من قبل الحكومه الامريكيه يجب
ان لا يتوقع الامريكيون المتواجدون في
السودان اخلاء من قبل الولايات المتحده في
هذا الوقت وانه من المتوقع ان يظل الوضع
هكذا في الوقت الحالي
ايضا مشاهدينا بعد اسبوع على المعارك
الطاحنه بدات عمليه اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
مهمه معقده خاصه مع انتشار المواجهات حول
مطار الخرطوم الدولي بهذا السياق اشارت كل
من الامم المتحده وامريكا وبريطانيا
واليابان وسويسرا وكوريا الجنوبيه والسويد
واسبانيا الى انها تجري استعدادات او
محاولات لابعاد موظفيها من الخرطوم بعد
نحو اسبوع من الاشتباكات في السودان
بدورها اوضحت قوات الدعم السريع انها
مستعده لفتح جميع مطارات السودان بشكل
جزئي حتى تتمكن الحكومات الاجنبيه من
اجلاء رعاياها
معنى من باريس الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
محمد الاسباط سيد محمد مساء الخير مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه دول كثيره تحاول
اخراج واجلاء رعاياها ومواطنيها من
السودان لكن برايك هل يمكن ان تنجح هذه
العمليه في ظل ما يشهده السودان اليوم من
مواجهات محتدمه تتركز حول مطار الخرطوم
بشكل محدد
تحيه لك وتحيه لمشاهدي قناه العربيه
واضح جدا ان عمليه الايلاء ستبدا خلال
ساعات وذلك من خلال عده معطيات
ابرزها ان يعني
جنرالات الحرب في الخرطوم
يسقون جيدا للخارج وخصوصا للغرب اوروبا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكنهم لا
يعني يعيرون اي التفاته لابناء شعبهم
الذين يعانون الامرين يعانون الموت يعانون
الجوع ويعانون
افتقار الخدمات ويعانون الامان
ويعانون معاناه يوميه استمرت لاسبوع واحد
من اكثر الاسابيع القصوى
عبر تاريخ العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم هذا
لا يعنيهم في شيء ولكن ما ان يرفع ايا من
المسؤولين الامريكيين او الاوروبيين سماعه
الهاتف حتى تجدهم يقولون سمعا وطاعه
مثلا
ما يؤكد ذلك ايضا صمود
الهدنه اليوم
اليوم الثاني لها
المواجهات كانت متقطعه ولفترات وجيزه جدا
وبالتالي
المتوقع
يعني على عجل ترتيب مدرجات في مطار
الخرطوم او في مطار او مطار كنانه هو مطار
مجهز بشكل جيد صحيح ليس
تقول عليه متوسط لا يبحث كثيرا عن العاصمه
الخرطوم
هنالك
يعني لكن نريد
يعني متابعه
ولكن اريد متابعه هذه واياك والمشاهدين
متابعه هذه الصور الان من محيط ربما
القياده العملي القوات المسلحه السودانيه
كما نشاهد اعمده الدخان تتصاعد يبدو ان
هناك ضربه مباشره قبل ثواني
في محيط القياده العملي القوات المسلحه
هذه المنطقه التي شهدت اشتباكات والسماع
دوي الانف جارات واطراق الرصاص المستمر في
هذه المنطقه تصاعد اعمده الدخان من محيط
هذه القياده القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه التي كما ذكرنا بان الجيش احكما
السيطره عليها نشر فيديوهات
من
ذات
المنطقه تقريبا منذ يوم امس وهو ينشر هذه
بعض وكالات الانباء لن نعود لنستمع الى
هذا الصوت لازال الصوت اذا المشاهدين ودوي
الانفجارات من هذه المنطقه
يعلو شيئا فشيئا وكاله انبات تتحدث اذا او
بيان للجيش السوداني بانه سيكون هناك
اجلاب للبعثه السعوديه برا الى بورتسودان
ومنها
جوا الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه وسيتم
تامين مغادره البعثه الاردنيه في وقت لاحق
بنفس الاسلوب هذه وكاله انباء اذا تنقل
هذه الاخبار
الان هذه الصوره التي ننقلها الان على
شاشه العربيه صور متفرقه من العاصمه
الخرطوم من محيط كذلك القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه تصاعد اعمده الدخان
لاحظ على يمين الشاشه وكذلك ايضا سماع دوي
اطلاق النار
وانفجارات كبيره اذا في العاصمه
الخرطوم يسمع ذويها منذ كما ذكرنا اسبوع
تتجدد بشكل مستمر نحاول ان نستمع الى صوت
طبيعي تمنعه
اذا استمعنا واياكم مشاهدينا
يعني الصوت الطبيعي من هذه المنطقه محيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه وبالقرب
منها ايضا بالعاصمه
الخرطوم اذا مشاهدينا نعود لمتابعه هذه
الصور نذكر فقط بان الجيش السوداني قال
بان البرهان تلقى اتصالات من رؤساء دول
لضمان
رعاياهم من السودان واضاف ايضا بان اجلال
رعايه امريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين
بطائرات عسكريه خلال ايضا
ساعات هذا ما نقله الجيش السوداني اذن
فيما يخص الرعايه ايضا الخارجيه السعوديه
قالت بانها بدات ترتيب اجلاءات المواطنين
السعوديين من ورعاية كذلك من دول شقيقه من
السودان
وكاله انباء ايضا نقلت بان اجلاء
البعثه او المواطنين السعوديين ايضا سيكون
برا الى بورتسودان ومنها جو الى السعوديه
سيد مغادره
البعثه الاردنيه في وقت لاحق بذات الاسلوب
اذا الان نعود للتذكير بهذه الصور اعمده
الدخان تتصاعد بشكل كبير من هذه المنطقه
محيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كان مراسل
العربيه ايضا قد افاد بان هناك تحليق
للطائرات للجيش السوداني فوق سماء الخرطوم
وبحري وام درمان
واتذكر بان هناك اصوات انفجارات متواصله
وتحليك كثيف للطيران في منطقه كرري بام
درمان النقابه اطباء السودان قالت للعربيه
بانه لا يوجد هناك اي التزام بالهدنه
والطواقم الطبيه لا تصل الى المستشفيات
نتحدث الان منذ بدايه هذه الازمه التي
تدخل اسبوعها الثاني بان هناك اكثر من خمس
الى ست هدن لم يتم الالتزام بها من كل
او من طرفي هذا اذا في السودان نعود
للتذكير بان هناك دولي لاطلاق النار
والسماع ايضا
لانفجارات في محيط القياده العامه
السودانيه في الخرطوم القصر الجمهوري ايضا
كذلك وهي التي تتركز حوله هذه المواجهات
بين الطرفي النزاع والصراع في السودان
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد مره اخرى
بين لحظه واخرى هناك انفجار كبير اذا الان
انفجار كبير يبدو امامنا الان على الشاشه
انفجار انفجار قوي في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم الان تصاعد لاعمده الدخان كما
شاهدنا واياكم مباشره
مشاهدينا في هذه الصور الخاصه
للعربيه انفجار كان هناك دبي كبير لانفجار
في العاصمه الخرطوم وبعد ذلك تصاعدت اعمده
الدخان كما نشاهد امامنا
الشاشه
بمرافقه طبعا اصوات الرصاص ورشقات الرصاص
المتواصله المستمره اذن الدوي اطلاق النار
وذوي انفجار كبير في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم لا تزال اعمده الدخان تتصاعد دون
توقف في هذه المنطقه لا نعلم ان كانت هناك
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في هذه المنطقه لكن من المعلوم
انها منطقه تدور حولها
الاشتباكات
السودانيه السودانيه الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع كر وفر في هذه المناطق منذ
اسبوع اذا هذه المشاهد لحريق اندلع بالقرب
من محيط القياده العامه في العاصمه
السودانيه
الخرطوم اعمده دخانه تتصاعد الان امامنا
على الشاشه السحب السوداء تغطي سماء
العاصمه السودانيه
انفجار ايضا اخر اصوات الانفجارات لم
تتوقف في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم منذ
ان بدات هذه الازمه في السودان وبعد فشل
التوصل الى
عمليه سياسيه والى انتقال ايضا ربما
ديمقراطي في
السودان وبعد ربما ان اتمت كل الاطراف
الاتفاق على رؤوس
الاقلام على الاقل للاتفاق الايطالي في
السودان لكن ما ان اعلن هذا الاتفاق بين
الاطراف ربما المدنيه والعسكريه ايضا حتى
انفجر هذا الخلاف والخلاف الكبير
المسلح بين البرهان وحميتي في السودان
والذي وصل الى اكثر من ولايه لم يقتصر فقط
على العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كنا نتابع
الاسبوع الماضي
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع على مطار مروي
والقاعده الموجوده في تلك المنطقه وبعدها
استعادها الجيش السوداني الان المعارك
ورحا هذه المعارك والصراع بين طرفي هذه
الازمه يدور في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
تحديدا في محيط العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
الى جانب ايضا القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه وطريق المطار ايضا كذلك جنوب
المطار بشكل خاص ربما تتسع دائره هذه
الازمه لتخرج الى خارج العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اذا هذه مشاهد كما ذكرنا لحريق
اندلع ابي القرب من محيط القياده العامه
في الخرطوم نعود لنذكر ببيان الجيش
السوداني الذي قال بان البرهان تلقى
اتصالات من رؤساء دول لضمان اجلاء راعيهم
من السودان
وذكر بانه سيكون هناك اجلاء لراعيه امريكا
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين بطائرات عسكريه
خلال ساعات الخارجيه السعوديه ايضا اعلنت
بدء ترتيب اجزاء المواطنين السعوديين
وراعي من دول شقيقه كذلك ايضا من السودان
ابقى مع هذه الصور نترككم
لمتابعه هذه الصور ولسماع الصوت الطبيعي
ثم نعود
[موسيقى]
ايضا مشاهدينا رغم الهدنه المعلنه لا تزال
هذه الاشتباكات متواصله في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وهذه المشاهد مباشره
امامكم وخاصه
شبكه العربيه ولقناه العربيه مشاهد لحريق
اندلع بالقرب من محيط القياده العامه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم سمع قبل هذا
الحريق دوي لانفجارات ايضا
كبيره وكذلك ايضا سمع لي ذوي اطلاق الرصاص
عود مره اخرى الى ضيفه من باريس الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي محمد الاسباط سيد محمد
مرحبا بك معي اذا رغم الهدنه التي اعلنت
لكنها يعني لا تكاد تعلن حتى يتم خرقها
نشاهد ذوي انفجارات اطلاق رصاص واشتباكات
ايضا حتى اعلان ربما عن قتلوا عن مصابين
في هذه
الاشتباكات برايك الى اين تتجه بوصله هذا
السلاح العسكري في السودان
سيد محمد هل تسمع الصراع
نعم اسمع هذا الصراع منذ يومه الاول هو
صراع التحكم والسيطره
كلا من الرجلين
يتوهمان او كل يتوهم بانه يستطيع ان يلحق
الهزيمه بالاخر
وبالتالي يقودان الحرب على حافه الهاويه
ولا يقيمان وزنا لاي
معايير اخلاقيه او معايير انسانيه
ولا يهتمان لمعالات هذه الحرب ولا تاثيرها
على المواطن ولا تاثير على صوره السودان
ولا تاثيرها على علاقات السودان الخارجيه
ولا تاثيرها على التراجع
المريع الذي سوف تشهده البلاد عقب الصمت
البنادق
السودان الخرطوم بالتحديد فيها بنيه تحتيه
متحركه على مدى اربع سنوات لم تتعرض لا
لصيانه ولا لتجديد والان تذكر
بالراجمات
الصغيره والمتوسطه والكبيره
وبالتالي
كل واحد من
بارونات الحرب يريد ان يثبت لنفسه ويؤكد
توهمي الشخصي بانه غادر على الحاق الخزينه
بالاخر وبالتالي لا في هذا في هذه العقليه
لا يوجد اي اعتبار للهدنه ايا كانت
دواعيها سواء كان انسانيه او
او لاسباب خاصه بالمواطن او الاسباب حتى
خاصه
بترتيبات دبلوماسيه كنا قبل قليل قد
تحدثنا
سيد محمد على مساله اجلاء الرعايه من
السودان ما هو الضامن
لسلامته مضامن لسلامه هذه العمليات
الضامن ان
قاعده الانقلاب عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
مليش الدعم السريع الحميدي
يعني جدان الاصغاء والركوع لاي اجنبي
خصوصا اذا كان هذا الاجنبي من اوروبا او
من امريكا
السلامه
اتوقع كما ذكرت في بدايه حديثي خلال ساعات
سيتم اجراء رعايه عدد من الدول في مطارات
كما ذكرت لك كنانه قريب من الخرطوم مدار
عتبه الغريب من الخرطوم ربما السودان ربما
بعد المطارات العسكريه في الخرطوم هي
مطارات صغيره ولكن
يعني استقبل الطائرات فقط اذا سمحت يعني
نحن نريد الحديث فقط عن هذه العمليات نريد
الحديث ايضا عن كيف ستتم عمليه ايضا حتى
تامينهم دون التعرض لاشخاص او التقليل او
الانتقاص ايضا حتى منهم بشكل شخصي او بشكل
مباشر اذا سمحت يعني لهم لكل من ذكر يعني
الاحترام والتقدير على المستوى الشخصي لكن
نحن فقط نريد ان نسال عنه سلامه الرعايه
كيف ستتم
الطعام لهذه العمليات ان كان هناك بدائل
ايضا لمطار الخرطوم
طبعا قبل الاجابه اذا سمحت لهذه الصور من
زاويه اخرى للانفجار والحريق الذي اندلع
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كما نشاهد
الان اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد من محيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه كما يبدو
في الصوره هي صوره اذا للعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اذن للحريق الذي اندلع بالقرب من
محيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه سمع
قبله ذوي انفجارات
وايضا كذلك حتى ربما اطلاق كذلك
الرصاص سمع دويه ايضا كذلك لكن السيد محمد
الاسباط اخيرا يعني قبل ان ننتقل الى ضيفي
الاخر كنت اسال عنه البدائل لمطار الخرطوم
ايضا للتامين سلامه الرعايه
السيد محمد لا طب ذكرت لك هنالك مطار
كنانه
ليس بعيدا من الخرطوم هنالك مطار عطبره
هنالك بطارات عسكريه في الخرطوم حول
الخرطوم درمان وبحري وهي رغم انها صغيره
ولكن يمكن ان تستقبل الطائرات صغيره
وطائرات متوسطه
ويمكن كما ذكرت ان
وفقا لتاريخ الرجلين الذين يخوضان الحرب
الان قائد الانقلاب او قائد مليش الدعم
السريع
تامين
وسيوقفان القتال في المناطق يوفرون مناطق
امنه لاجلاء
الدبلوماسيين الاجانب لان تاريخ الرجلين
اثبت انهم لا يعيان اهتماما بالسوداني
كثيرا ولكنهم يصغون الاجانب خصوصا من
اوروبا وامريكا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
وجودك معي محمد الاسواط والصيحه في
السوداني والذي من باريس يعود مره اخرى
الى الخرطوم والى اللواء الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز الدراسات الدوليه دكتور امين مرحبا
بك معي مره اخرى يعني بدويه الانفجارات
كبيره جدا في العاصمه الخرطوم اعمده
الدخان وسيله اللهب ايضا كذلك حتى تتصاعد
الان من محيط القياده العملي القوات
المسلحه كيف تقيم هذا المشهد الذي نشاهده
الان على شاشه العربيه بشكل مباشر
بعد الهدوء الذي كانت في صباح اليوم
متقطعه من الاسلحه والمساجات وضح الان انه
في اشتباك اكبر وربما في
مستودعات وقود او مبنى من المباني في تجاه
محطه المواصلات
خارج الحكومه وغرب الخرطوم يبدو ان هذا
المبلغ الاصيب
ما زالت طبعا المعارك الشوارع مستمره ولا
قياس
لانتهائها باعتبار كانت مطارده الشوارع
الفرعيه خارج العاصمه تماما اليوم تسللت
بعض المجموعات
وهم هدفهم الرئيس طبعا منطقه الوسط
العسكريه والمباني السياديه وبعض المواقع
الاقتصاديه هذا هو الهدف لذلك سيكون كلنا
نتحدث عن منطقه محيط القياده العامه
والمشاريع المطار والجنوب الخرطوم لكن
الواضح ان هذه مجموعه صغيره اما اشتعال
النيران فاغلب المباني الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه مباني جديده
وتغطى بالكلاد البلاستيك لذلك اي اشتباك
اي اصابه مباشره بتعمل على اجعل النيران
في هذه المواقع لكن هذه يعني ما هي نوعيه
هذه الابنيه يعني هل هي السكنيه هل هي
حكوميه هل هي عسكريه ايضا كذلك دكتور امين
اغلب هذه المواقع هي عسكريه والسياديه
وزارات مصالح حكوميه
وبعض المدارس في هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه
طبعا منذ يعني الاستغلال كانت بها
مباني الحكومه الانجليزيه لذلك هي مباني
عتيقه المصيانتها واضافه مباني جديده لها
ولذلك تشمل نفس المباني العسكريه
والسياديه والاقتصاديه
والطريق يعود الى المطار يعني طريق المطار
به مباني سكنيه
غربا الى الى ان تصل الى الى نهر النيل
وبالتالي ايضا الشرق المطار وشرق القياده
العامه يوجد حي الرياض من الاحياء الجديده
يمتد حتى المنشيه وحتى
نهر النيل او النيل الازرق هذا هو وضع
الجزيره لذلك كل الخدمات متوفره في الوسط
وهذه المنطقه ستكون فيها منطقه
الى ان يحين دكتور اذا سمحت يعني هذه
المنطقه هل يمكن القول بان من يستطيع
احكام السيطره على وسط الخرطومه هي هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد يستطيع كم السيطره على
كل مفاصل الدوله وعلى الاقل حتى العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
نعم هي المنطقه المستهدفه الان هي القياده
العامه لانه في هذا العام فيها التواجد
للقيادات وتزار منها المعارك لكن هي مؤمنه
هذه المناوشات على بعد اثنين كيلو الى
ثلاثه كيلو معناها ثلاثه شوارع لمن عاشوا
ثلاثه شوارع تتجه من الشرق الى الغرب من
القياده العامه على هذه المنطقه المؤثره
اما الاسوار فهي اصوات المضادات الارضيه
للطيران مزعجه حقيقه واكواب عاليه هي التي
نسمعها الان اصوات المضادات مضادات طيران
طيب السؤال ايضا عن سيناريو وامتداد ساحه
الصراع ايضا والاشتباكات بين الطرفين الى
خارج حدود العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
دكتور هل هذا مرجح وان كان نعم اين سيكون
بالامس مرحله المطارده والتمشيط عده لخروج
بعض المجموعات من الدعم السريع جنوبا
وشمالا من العاصمه وحتى منطقه ام درمان
وبالتالي يرجح اذا انهزمت وخرجت فانت تتجه
الى مناطور فقط لانه عندها الحاضر الشعبيه
هناك والحاضنه القبليه ولا ننسى ان هنالك
تداخل غبري بين المجموعات المكونه للدعم
السريع من عشائر معينه لديها امتدادات
قبليه مع دول الجوار الغربي لذلك هذا هو
الاتجاه
المفضل لها والمرجح والان ايضا تتم تغطيته
يعني لا يترك الخروج
بنفس
الاعتبارات لكن بيتم تغطيه بيتم محاوله
حسم هذا الامر حتى لا يتعود الى ولايات
اخرى الولايات الاخرى ما عندها نفس
امكانيات العاصمه اذا كانت العاصمه الان
تاسفت كثيرا بالقضاء الانسانيه
والمستشفيات والكهرباء والمياه فما بالك
بالولايات اذا انتقلناها من صراع تتنافس
كثيرا
وحسب ما ورد في تقريركم قبل قليل يعني
المفضل وتجرير اداره الازمات ان لا ينقرض
الجموع القبليه في هذا الصراع حتى لا
تتحول الى حرب اهليه وهذا سؤال مهم ايضا
كذلك دكتور انه هذه القبائل والحاضنه
القبليه كيف ستؤثر بشكل مباشر على هذه
الازمه بين الطرفين
من الاشياء الايجابيه اعتبر البيانات امس
واول امس من بعض القبائل في دارف ترفض هذا
الصراع وتطلب من ابنائها بالدعم السريعه
انهم يسلم انفسهم للقوات المسلحه وايضا
بيان من قبائل العربيه تشات وايضا يعني
يحدث عن انهم تم خداع ابنائهم
وتم يعني زجهم في هذه المعركه الخاتره مع
جيش الوطني عريق من الجيش السوداني
وبالتالي هم كانوا يتحدثون انهم لا دخل
لهم بهذه المعركه وهذه معركه اشخاص وافراد
بمعنى
يقوم على على اسره لذلك هذه من الايجابيات
انه ما في تخوف منه بانتقال هذه المجموعات
الى دارفور مره اخرى ولكن هي فقط مساله
ايجاد وسايكل بعيش غير التكسب من العمل
العسكري الذي زرع بنظام السابق واحده من
الاطفال لزرع النظام السابق اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على الانضمام معي في هذه التغطيه من
الخرطوم لواء الدكتور امين اسماعيل الخبير
الامني والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات
الدولي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات